in this project we'll be exploring
fixing floating point precision issues
logarithmic depth buffers and problems
of scale
it's been a while but in the last videos
we introduced floating
origins as a way of expanding our worlds
to actual
planetary sized things instead of dinky
little asteroids and moons
but going planet scale brings planet
scale problems
and we were left with a bit of a mess so
today we're addressing those problems
specifically we want to be able to stand
here on the ground and look around and
everything looks fine and then we want
to zoom out to deep into space and float
there
and everything still looks fine but we
don't want this
see how the ground textures look kind of
chunky and generally pretty crappy
and if we go out a bit look at all the
zed fighting and problems with the
terrain
let's start with the zed fighting first
thing we need to do is
understand exactly what is in the depth
buffer
we touched on this a bit in the soft
particles video but basically when you
transform coordinates through to screen
or window coordinates
you go through a few spaces the
perspective w divide here makes the
transformation non-linear
and since w is actually the view depth
then the final depth value
is directly related to 1 over z i did
the whole derivation in that video
but in short the view space depth is
equal to the r times the near plane
divided by
the z final times far minus near minus
var
okay what does that mean let's graph
that so we'll end up with a graph that
looks something like this
view space depth is along the x-axis and
the values in the depth buffer are the
y-axis
and this is so steep that we can barely
make out what's happening
so let's change it to log scale now that
it's clear
notice some crazy things like nearly all
of the precision
is clumped up near the near plane like
only one meter past the near plane we
used up nearly fifty percent of the
depth values already
and at ten meters ninety percent of
depth values are used up
this obviously depends on which near and
far plane you use
but depth buffers aren't infinite
precision so let's simulate this using a
depth buffer with say
8 bits of precision that means on the
left we have 256 discrete possibilities
for the values in the depth buffer
by the time you're 100 meters out you
can barely distinguish between an object
that's 100 meters and 200 meters away
and past that a single value has to
cover the last 80 percent of the range
which is just absurd so what do we want
to draw planetary scales we probably
want the graph to look more like this
with the slope of the line looking
pretty straight when plotted with log
scale
meaning the depth values are allocated
more evenly depending on distance
there is an older technique called w
buffering which basically used linear
depth values
but that never caught on there's no
hardware support
but it gives us a nice idea on what the
solution to this might look like
let's talk solutions somewhat known in
directx circles
you can use an inverted floating point
depth buffer but nvidia outlines here in
this article why it doesn't work in
webgl since you need a specific
extension
another great trick is something called
logarithmic depth buffers
which has been written about a couple
times each having slightly different
approaches
the general idea is to write out your
own depth using log scaling
so plunking that into our graph we get
damn near a straight line
and examining the values what ends up
happening is that we've pushed some of
that somewhat
useless precision that was right by the
near plane much further out
let's code this up so i feel kind of bad
because that explanation made this sound
like it was going to be a hassle to
implement
but it's just passing a value from the
vertex to fragment shader and then
writing out gl frag depth using that log
equation
so yeah just a couple quick lines of
code and you're good to go we can look
around and the problems have kind of
evaporated
now keep in mind this isn't totally free
writing to
gl frag depth can hurt some hardware
optimizations but
it's not a big deal and if you're using
3.js and the default shaders you can
just enable logarithmic depth buffers
during initialization and it's all done
magically for you
but there's one problem if you haven't
spotted it already i'll give you a
second
notice the scattering it's gone the
problem now is that we're writing log
depth out to the depth buffer which
means when we read the depth buffer we
need to convert it back
and we have to do this ourselves since
3.js doesn't implement that
here in the shader we're going to
reconstruct the view space depth by
reversing the log calculation
so if v depth equals 1 plus w w being v
space depth
and the depth buffer value is log 2 v
depth times
x reversed this should be view depth
equals 2 to the power
value divided by x minus one and then to
recreate world space
we can construct the eclipse-based
coordinate reverse the projection and
set the magnitude
and we're all good the scattering is
back but there's a second problem
which is the textures look terrible and
the problem is that we're trying to work
with these massive world space
coordinates in the fragment shader
my first solution was what if we could
wrap the coordinates into some sort of
repeating range
like a sine wave so i hit up the vertex
shader and random through a sine
function
and it's almost it kinda works but we
get these weird stretchy bands near the
peaks and troughs of the sine wave
so almost but not quite luckily on
wikipedia i found this
a triangle wave which is a
non-sinusoidal wave that goes up and
down linearly
so hopefully no stretchy bands the
vertex shader code is straightforward
just need to drop
and replace the sign with the triangle
wave function
and we're all good to go problems
largely gone at this point
i'm not sure if those triangle waves are
the ultimate solution here
but they've at least tucked the problem
away nicely so i'm calling it a win
at least for now if you have better
ideas definitely let me know
otherwise subscribe buy me a coffee on
patreon
and i'll see you later cheers